dylan bundy trying to replicate his last
start two starts ago he was pretty good
he gave up three runs in that first
inning against oakland no runs after
that and no runs on a thursday at texas
george springer leads it off yeah
there's a swing and a miss a sinker 90
miles an hour by him because of his
curveball the pitch before the spot and
he runs a fastball right by him that
deception great spot challenging with a
fastball gets a swing miss one batter
one strikeout
wanted to simeon
with buchet out tonight slides over to
his more natural shortstop position to
wright's eating in eaton back
and he makes the catch i love the way he
plays always with a smile on his face
slips sliding away makes the play vlad
jr
high
but not too deep it's going to be
brandon marsh there with joe adele right
beside him boy he really crowded march
he makes the call and catch and that'll
end the inning making his 11th career
start and he has gotten off to a
historic start in his young career he's
allowed four hits or few in all 10 of
his career starts that's the longest set
streak to start a career in major league
history
oh tony 1 0
and it is yanked to right field hit
pretty well but the catch is made by t
oscar hernandez play oh tony is so
strong he just was out in front a little
bit off stride but he still hit it on
the line right to the fence in right
field of course the oscar's going to
play deep to respect the power of ohtani
and he gets a good break and one stride
onto the warning track and then makes a
nice catch point to oscar we talked
about how much he has improved at the
plate he's improved dramatically in the
outfield as well and i think he likes
the fact that most of the time he's
going to be in right field so one down
bottom of the first here's the second
baseman david fletcher
ground ball to short simeon it's short
tonight with pachette out of the lineup
two down so with two down now jared walk
swinging a miss he got him with a
fastball
first strikeout of the night for alec
manoa spins a perfect bottom first the
lead off man aboard the batter now will
be the center fielder brandon marsh
swing and a miss to get him marsh goes
into the glove second strikeout for
manoa max stassi the catcher for the
angels one two and look at that slide
nasty stuff as he gets them swinging two
down yeah and you know what that slider
is very tight very good and when you
look at how he finishes his delivery the
ball comes out of his hand in the same
angle as his fastball then hitters have
a difficult time identifying that it's a
breaking ball two down and here's adame
a hot shot down to first a nice play by
goriel he lunges over taps the cushion
with the glove to retire eaton no score
going to the top of the third and lurtis
goriel junior
as he sends a fly ball to left field it
is well hit and it's gone number 13 on
the season for goriel and it looked like
he hit the catcher on the back swing
also hits it out for a home run and the
blue jays take a one-to-nothing lead boy
how about that when guerrielle felt the
catcher with his backswing but it was
after the fact he'd already squared it
out and they're breaking out the home
run jacket early blue jays
they put that jacket on the guy to hit
some home run and they're celebrating a
one-nothing lead for guriel bluejay's
leading one-nothing top of the card for
george springer two balls in two strikes
springer lifts one to left field this
ball is well struck and it's gone as
well
number 15 on the season for springer and
it is two to nothing blue jays
knew when he turned that curve ball
loose that it wasn't going to end up in
a good spot and spearhead what a
beautiful swing he had he just had a
little bit of hesitation to allow that
curveball to come to him and then he
turned and smoked
the next batter and the counts one ball
two strikes
shohei swings and lifts a high drive to
dead center field it is out of here
he got it out that time against manoa
ohtani connects home run number 38 that
one ties up the game at two and how
about it wednesday night it's showtime
shohei that lays off the fastball the
pitch before at 94 well above the strike
zone lays off
manoa comes back with the slider this
one is down in the zone he goes down and
gets it and smokes it dead center and
ties this game up at two brandon marsh
two balls and two strikes and they come
right back and get a strikeout going
away with the fastball but again his
fastball is got a lot of life tonight
the two-seamer was the one that didn't
get the call and now he just muscles up
on a four-seamer at 95 away the angels
catcher 2-2 again and he got him up and
in swinging to miss strikeout number six
yeah and you know this is the beauty of
alec manual and you know he gave up the
whole run to ohtani he probably rethink
that pitch but it's not an issue for him
now two down for atomy
look at that swing alec manoa strikes
out the side in the fourth inning one
down here at the fifth for santiago
espinal it's a 2-2 tie in the fifth
inning
espinal and finds a hole on the right
side for a base head burial around third
heading home he'll score throw to second
is not in time and the blue jays take
the lead santiago espinal just figures
out a way to do something every time he
plays got a big rbi guy coming to the
plate into oscar hernandez the blue jays
with the bases loaded leading 3-2
looking for more
he lifts one to left field deep and a
grand slam
forte oscar hernandez the first of his
majorly career and the blue jays now
lead seven to two and that jack is
getting a workout tonight
third time they've broken out the home
run jacket runner with second two down
and here's lourdes gurio jr
and there's a basin into right field
dickerson around third he'll come home
to score
as eaton lobs the ball into second and
it is nine to two
want to win a game for alertus hit the
home run in the third inning it was the
first run for the blue jays and then he
has just continued to hit up and one
down here comes george springer
springer turns on another one and this
will be his second home run of the night
nobody's been hotter coming out of the
break then george springer ten to two
toronto in front there are two outs in
the bottom of the nine that task will
belong to jack mayfield
and this is going to do it mayfield pops
it up goriel is there and the blue jays
will win it the blue jays are flying
high in this one they win running away
10-2
you